as millions of Americans head to the
coast this holiday week there are new
concerns about rare but potentially
deadly flesh-eating bacteria found in
warm waters one woman Lynn Fleming died
last week when she was infected after a
fall at a beach
now after families now families are
sounding the alarm we spoke to a Florida
man who says he was infected without
even getting wet so it started right
here and it just kind of worked its way
out Tyler King was at work in Santa Rosa
Beach Florida last week when he noticed
his left bicep starting to swell King
tried taking benadryl but just a few
hours later his arm had nearly tripled
in size and he rushed to the emergency
room I was a little bit younger I
probably would have tried to tough it
out well that would have been the worst
thing I could do King had contracted
Vibrio a bacteria commonly found in warm
brackish water which is a mix of salt
and fresh water when exposed to an open
wound Vibrio can cause a skin infection
if left untreated the bacteria can be
deadly if I gone to sleep that night and
woken up at the rate that was spreading
up I might not have a norm right now
King who runs a watersports business
says he did not directly touch water the
day he was infected he still doesn't
know how it happened but he considers
himself lucky my arms looking pretty
good most of the swelling has gone down
and the rash has completely gone away
similar cases of infection have been
popping up on beaches along the East
Coast
a Maryland woman says her son is healing
after he developed open wounds swimming
in a bay last week a 77 year old woman
who was walking along the Gulf died
after developing necrotizing fasciitis
when she fell in the water and cut her
leg the waters are getting warmer and
the bacteria love warmer water so we're
all at higher risk CBS News medical
contributor dr. David agus says the key
to stopping flesh-eating bacteria is to
catch and treat infections with
antibiotics quickly older people with
medical conditions like diabetes cancer
or immune deficiencies are more
susceptible once that bacteria has
spread in the bloodstream to the organs
sometimes it's too hard to treat but
just
attention don't be afraid of the ocean
but be aware of what's going on dr. agus
gave us some other recommendations for
staying safe this summer check yourself
and your children often for cuts cover
any cuts with waterproof band-aids
before getting into the ocean and if you
don't get a cut in the water clean it
with hand sanitizer immediately and keep
monitoring cuts for any signs of
infection like swelling or redness
advice yeah once you get it it seems to
move very quickly it's very unsightly do
it is alright de Rica